schnellere computer und riesige
verknüpfte datenbanken ermöglichen jetzt
einen komplett neuen ansatz in der
heilkunde die präzisions medizin
was das genau ist und wieso es
vielleicht einmal dein leben retten wird
erfährst du jetzt bei clixoom motto
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge
unser körper ist ein unglaublich
kompliziertes und verknüpfte system das
wir immer noch nicht vollständig
verstanden haben
deshalb ist es auch kein wunder dass wir
heutzutage bei fast jeder krankheit mit
kanonen auf spatzen schießen
eine chemotherapie greift zum beispiel
nicht nur bösartige krebszellen an
sondern einfach alle zellen die sich
schnell teilen so wird nicht nur der
tumor geschwächt sondern gleich das
ganze immunsystem des körpers das
ergebnis dem patienten geht es hunde
elend im fallen haare aus und er ist
extrem anfällig gegenüber infekten aber
mit ein bisschen glück wird die
chemotherapie in 20 oder 30 jahren etwa
so aktuell erscheinen wie die
amputationen mit einem weil denn mit
hilfe von präziseren messtechniken und
riesigen datenbanken kann die präzisions
medizin eine viel gezieltere und somit
effektivere therapie bereitstellen
das funktioniert heute zum beispiel
schon bei brustkrebs etwa ein fünftel
aller brustkrebspatienten können
aufgrund eines bestimmten moleküls mit
antikörpern behandelt werden diese
blockieren präzise dieses einem molekül
ohne den rest des körpers anzugreifen
und weil diese methode so viel einfacher
und angenehmer für den patienten ist als
eine chemotherapie gehört es inzwischen
zum standard den brustkrebs der
patienten auf genau dieses molekül hin
zu untersuchen
und genau so stellen sich ernste den
traum der präzisions medizin vor ein
brustkrebs wird in der zukunft nicht
einfach nur einen brustkrebs seien sowie
die patienten ist auch der tumor selber
individuell hat einen eigenen
stoffwechsel und spezifische genetische
veränderungen so entstehen viele kleine
untergruppen je besser die krankheit
identifiziert und klassifiziert wird
desto präziser und genauer kann die
therapie dafür sein
doch für ärzte selber ist diese aufgabe
viel zu umständlich bei einer
genetischen analyse eines tumors
erkennen wir zwischen 1.000 und 10.000
genetische unterschiede zum gesunden
gewebe des patienten jeden einzelnen
unterschied zu untersuchen und mit
studien zu vergleichen wurde einfach
monate dauern
doch dank der heutigen technik ist es
nun endlich möglich innerhalb weniger
minuten ein sehr aufschlussreiches
ergebnis zu erhalten
und zwar mit hilfe von datenbanken über
jahre hinweg wurden fallstudien
anonymisierte patientenakten und
krankheitsverläufe in eine riesige
datenbank eingepflegt doch erst die
verknüpfung der einzelnen krankheiten
untereinander macht die datenbank so
wertvoll denn so können die ärzte
erfahren ob der patient mit seiner
speziellen vorgeschichte gut oder
schlecht auf die geplante therapie
reagieren wird viele krankheiten können
sich gegenseitig beeinflussen und
erfordern so ein individuelles handeln
für jeden patienten menschliche
erfahrung ist da schnell über fragt die
präzisions medizin geht sogar noch einen
schritt weiter
durch die analyse der miteinander
verknüpften krankheiten fallen immer
wieder musste auf die vorher noch nicht
bekannt war
so treten zb bei kindern die an diabetes
erkranken oft bereits zwei jahre zuvor
änderungen der aminosäure muster auf es
kann also möglich sein den ausbruch von
krankheiten vorherzusagen teilweise
jahre im voraus
das kann uns genug zeit geben präventiv
zu handeln und sogar den ausbruch der
krankheit komplett zu verhindern bevor
es überhaupt passiert ist wahrscheinlich
möchten viele von euch gar nicht wissen
wann und wie sie erkranken
aber wenn unser arzt präventiv bescheid
wüsste und unseren lebensstil in die
richtige richtung lenken könnte dann
würden wir wahrscheinlich alle ein
gesünderes und glücklicheres leben
führen
was meint ihr präzisions medizin ja auf
jeden fall oder seid ihr da doch eher
skeptisch schreibt mir auf jeden fall
eure meinung unten in die kommentare ich
bin sehr gespannt auf eure meinung
ansonsten könnt ihr hier oben ein
kostenloses hörbuch von audible bekommen
und hier gibt's die beiden letzten
folgen von what's on selbstfahrende
autos oben uns die stadt der zukunft
unten vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis
zum nächsten mal